ja danke dass ich hier den Raum bekomme
um so ein bisschen meine Sichtweise zu
dem Thema und aber auch vor allem meine
Erfahrungen zu schildern ich bin bei dem
ganzen Thema sehr experimentell
unterwegs das heißt ich probiere es
einfach aus und spiele herum auf gut
deutsch und glaube aber dass das ja hier
einfach spannende Sachen zu entdecken
sind
dementsprechend ich werde auf die
Funktionalität wie EA funktioniert diese
bildgeneratoren eingehen Image
Generators und dann halt einige
Beispiele zeigen wie es klappt wo es gut
klappt wo es Probleme gibt und alles
halt hoffe ich mit ganz netten Bildern
die auch Spaß machen anzuschauen ähm
hier rechts seht ihr schon das
allererste Bild im Vortrag ähm und da da
da seht ihr ja da steht einfach viel
Artikel style of das ist was ich
eingetippt habe bei dem Programm mit
journey und das kam dann
glücklicherweise direkt raus oft muss
man da viele
Dekoration durchgehen bis was Gutes
rauskommt manchmal hat man Glück und so
wird es dann auch im Laufe des Vortrags
immer sein also wenn ihr euch fragt was
habe ich eingegeben dann ist das
meistens markiert manchmal bewusst aber
auch nicht markiert
ja also genau dann kurz zum zum
ganzen Ding also als als vorweg es hat
halt eine exponentielle Entwicklung des
ganze ich habe hier mal für ein Artikel
den ich geschrieben habe ein Bild
gesucht oder gebraucht und eben wollte
einen Kapitalisten darstellen und habe
dann eben geschrieben Mister Monopoly
ist triumfing over the capital
background full of money and Dada points
und dann kam das raus okay hier mit
journey Version 3 und ich war so cool
alles klar ist ist ein nettes Ergebnis
ich kann damit arbeiten ich werde jetzt
irgendwie noch mal einen Tag dran sitzen
und dann ein paar Interaktionen machen
bis ich das habe was ich brauche und
dann lese ich auf einmal das ist
Universum gibt und dann habe ich das
natürlich um gestellt denselben Text
genommen und das war das Ergebnis
so
und das ist halt in drei Monaten also es
sind drei Monate Unterschied dazwischen
diesen zwei
Versionen ja und dann dachte ich jetzt
ist wirklich vorbei ich muss nicht mehr
ich muss nicht mehr zeichnen kein
Photoshop gar nichts brauche ich mehr
und
ja war auf jeden Fall sehr geflasht und
dann seitdem spiele ich halt viel rum
und mache mit der ganzen Sache taucht
dann dieses Thema ein ich will aber auch
ein Gegenbeispiel bringen also dasselbe
Spiel noch mal ich habe hier was
eingegeben gehabt bei Version 3 und war
total zufrieden mit dem Ergebnis es hat
mich ja irgendwie so ja auch ja Artico
war sie nie Kandinsky ich weiß es nicht
irgendwas Anfang 20 jahrhundertmäßiges
erinnert und äh fand das total toll und
dann habe ich halt für den Vortrag jetzt
noch mal getestet was rauskommt bei der
Vision 4 und das ist halt hier ein ganz
anderes Bild das ist ein Gebäude es ist
dreidimensional es ist realistisch und
man muss bedenken ich habe hier exakt
dieselbe Beschreibung gegeben auch wenn
das vielleicht realistische aussieht
würde ich nicht sagen dass es ein
schöneres Bild ist oder so und
das heißt aber nicht dass die Version 4
das nicht könnte sondern einfach dass
ich ihn Version 4 einen anderen Befehle
eingeben muss
nichtsdestotrotz beide Bilder hier beide
Beispiele bringen den Punkt es
entwickelt sich exponentiell schnell und
heute eine Stunde vom Vortag habe ich
auf Twitter gesehen dass es jetzt sogar
ein Tool gibt was aus diesen generierten
Bildern man nimmt so ein generiertes
Bild man filmt irgendwas mit seiner
Handykamera tut es beides im Programm
rein und bekommt dann in diesem Stil ein
Video raus animiert das hat mich total
geflasht kann man sich ja noch mal
anschauen danach also das geht gerade
schneller voran als wir gucken können
das ganze okay jetzt zum Hintergrund
dieser ganzen Technologie wir haben
diese Text zu bildgeneratoren ganz
prominent seit 2021 der Vorläufer hieß
latent die Fusion also das ist ja
Algorithmus von dem ganzen und die
Ergebnisse waren relativ und präzise man
kann da ein Beispiele finden im Internet
ich habe da schon früh rumgespielt aber
es war halt eben ja also da war man früh
mit der Frage konfrontiert okay was für
ein Bild nimmt man jetzt eigentlich und
und und also man musste sich wirklich
hinsetzen und und klar Gedanken machen
so was davon ist irgendwie künstlerisch
oder visuell ästhetisch interessant
ja ein Jahr danach stable de fusion ist
auf einmal da anscheinend wurde das von
der LMU mit entwickelt von einem Lab
vielleicht kennen sich davon euch auch
paar Leute aus auf jeden Fall ähm fand
ich das ein fun fact und stable die
Fusion war dann auf einmal ein Open
Source Algorithmus sind alle benutzen
konnten zu Nutze haben sich das halt vor
allem diese Firmen open ai und mit
journey gemacht und haben das dann als
Cloud Service angeboten seit dem Sommer
letzten Jahres und man zahlt da halt
eben ein bisschen so ein Monatsbeitrag
für die Serverleistung die da
aufgebracht werden muss damit diese
Bilder überhaupt berechnet werden können
braucht auch unglaublich viel Strom so
und ja ist halt teuer deswegen kann ich
das verstehen
nichtsdestotrotz hat jeder von uns die
Möglichkeit stability Fusion
runterzuladen seine eigene Datenbank
damit einzuspeisen und die Technologie
für sich zu nutzen oder halt wie viele
tun zu kommerzialisieren da gibt es auch
ein witziges meme was ich nicht drin
habe aber das sagt halt im Prinzip so
dass jeder der halt irgendwie diesen
Algorithmus in der App packt auf einmal
ein Ei Developer ist obwohl er halt
nichts die erlaubt hat ja also da kann
man auch ja vielen solchen Firmen
begegnen ähm genau wie funktioniert das
Ganze im Prinzip bringt man oder sagt
man dem Algorithmus er soll ich zeig's
mal hier in dem Bild in dem nächsten
Bild das ganz relativ eindringlich man
sagt man hat hier ein originales Bild
das ist die Datenbank von dem Hund und
dann sagt man dem hey bitte mach das mal
neu sie zu hier
wie sagt man das auf deutsch bestimmen
das Bild und und merk dir den Prozess
das ist der erste Schritt dann macht er
das der merkt sich das wie das
funktioniert und dann sagt er halt hey
in dem hier irgendein random random
verschwommenes Bild random neues Bild
und
transformiert macht denselben Prozess
aber andersrum und dann kommt wieder ein
Hund raus der Hund ist aber ein ganz
anderer und jetzt kann man halt sagen so
ja und das ist eine wichtige Kerne
Information zum Prozess also das später
gehe ich noch mal drauf ein wie wie wir
also bei der ganzen Frage geklautes
Bilder oder nicht müssen wir also
sollten wir das als Grundlage nehmen für
die Diskussion
ja zum Energieverbrauch wollte ich hier
noch mal zeigen
ich habe ich also ich bin ja auch im
Bitcoin Bereich sehr sehr tief drin und
und Forscher aufschreibe macht Vorträge
und so und bin eben da in Kontakt mit
ein paar Leuten und und habe halt eben
hier in dem Podcast auch herausgefunden
von einem ethereum Entwickler das die
ganzen Server die bis letzten Jahres für
smining benutzt wurden von ethereum also
nicht Bitcoin sondern Imperium müssen
andere kryptowährung dass diese ganzen
Geräte ähm mit einem Update nicht mehr
gebraucht wurden also die blockchaine
Interio hat keine hat diese meiner nicht
mehr gebraucht das waren halt also
wirklich tausende von Computern und
Rechenleistungen die dann einfach
rumstand weil die Ferien ein Update
gemacht hat wo dieses mining nicht mehr
benötigt wird und genau diese Geräte
wurden dann lustigerweise kann man sagen
oder halt nicht so lustigerweise werden
halt jetzt für
gegen Geld für diese ai Generator
benutzt und man sieht hier sind so 78
Terawatt Stunden pro Jahr die ethereum
gebraucht hatte nur so als Beispiel
Youtube und Google braucht also oder
oder YouTube braucht seit viel mehr für
Streaming und so man also bei der
Energie Frage muss man sich immer also
würde ich nicht per se sagen dass es
schlecht man muss immer den Nutzen
Hinterfragen von der ganzen Sache
und und auch ganz prominentes Beispiel
Chichi haben auch alle sicherlich
mitbekommen das braucht es kosten
ungefähr 1 Millionen Euro pro Tag das
und es wird von noch mehr Leuten
verwendet ich glaube die ist die
Plattform mit den meisten Nutzern gerade
die es gibt im Internet
so ja also jetzt haben wir die Kosten
abgedeckt wir haben die Funktionsweise
abgedeckt und jetzt vielleicht zum zu
Ästhetik also das ganze funktioniert
Text zu Bild das wo so wird es genannt
und das führt dazu dass wir hier auch
eigentlich uns Bewusstsein also uns
Bewusstsein sollte dass es auch hier
Stilmittel gibt und man selber den Ziel
beeinflussen kann also es passiert eben
nicht alles automatisch
ich habe hier die Version oder ein
Beispiel von dem Kaktus seinem
lächelnden Kaktus der in einem tree
forest meditiert mit shiny flowers und
ein goldenen Staub während dem
Sonnenuntergang das ist die Szene die
ich beschrieben habe und die Szene
sozusagen diese Beschreibung will ich
jetzt in diesem Beispiel ähm fixiert
haben die soll sich nicht ändern das da
bin ich mir klar und ähm das Gute ist
aber auch dass man eben variable Stile
dazu hinzufügen kann das heißt mein
prompt textbefehl ist eben diese
Beschreibung oben und hier unten links
seht ihr dann abstract painting style
das sind alles Sachen auch auf die ich
irgendwie experimentieren gekommen bin
ja also da gibt es auch Communities und
so die sich über diese Befehle
austauschen was halt am besten oder
spannendsten funktioniert und das war
dann das Ergebnis und so kann man halt
eben weitermachen mit Black and White
drawing dann kommt sowas hier raus in
die Beschreibung bleibt immer dieselbe
oder hier voll the paper cut Artwork
dann haben wir hier so also super
realistisches Bild von so einem
papierkaktus oder eben 3D modeling
das selbe also das ist halt genau das
sind diese Kakteen das selbe geht auch
andersrum dass man sagt man hat eine
Variable Beschreibung der Szenerie und
einen fixierten Style das habe ich halt
hier gemacht also wir haben Links ähm
eben also der Stieles schwarz-weiß mit
Kohle gezeichnet und die Beschreibung
ist eben ein ein also immer ein nineteen
seventies Model Museum building und das
habe ich dann angepasst den zweiten und
dritten Bild einmal als als riesigen ja
Ballon und und dann als Pyramide und das
soll halt verdeutlichen wie viel
Gedanken Arbeit eigentlich auch rein
fließt in so ein Bild weil es eben also
um solche Ergebnisse zu bekommen ja also
wenn man die Pyramide hat das schon viel
davon passiert dass man überhaupt auf
die Idee von der Pyramide kommt
genau so und jetzt ist natürlich die
große Kernfrage ist ki-kunst raubt die
steht im Raum und hier ist es halt so
als Beispiel nur
Albrecht Dürer Hans drawing habe ich mal
einfach ganz plakativ eingegeben da kam
vier Ergebnisse raus ich habe das in
Anführungsstrichen beste oder dem
Originalbild am nächsten genommen und
und das ist halt merkwürdig ja also die
die Finger sind leider schafft es immer
noch nicht ich dachte so kurzes sie
haben das Problem mit den Fingern gelöst
aber so ganz ist es auch noch nicht
gelöst
und das ist alles ai generated und da
könnte man sagen ja das ist eigentlich
schon geklaut oder oder es ist es nimmt
halt die originale als Vorbild aber wenn
ich wirklich das Bild soll ich mal
klauen will warum mache ich einfach
nicht mit einer Google Suche und nimm
dann einfach das Originalbild und ja so
das ist nur eine Gegenüberstellung dass
man mal sieht wenn man wenn man wirklich
eins zu eins Google Suche vs generated
Bild wie der Unterschied so ist man kann
das sicher auch anders bewerten das ist
da bin ich glaube ich offen für dass man
da drüber diskutiert
genau das Bild hier noch mal zum zum
raubthema ich wie gesagt ich finde es
erklärt sehr gut also man hat die
originalen Bilder von allen möglichen
Künstlern Künstlern die philosophische
moralische Frage ist natürlich
sollten wir diese Künstler nicht um
Einwilligung bitten ob die Bilder
überhaupt in der Datenbank sind ich
glaube da sollte man ansetzen aber sagen
wir mal der Punkt die sind jetzt schon
in der Datenbank und ein Bild wird
generiert da ist es eben so dass das was
rauskommt wird nicht einfach copy Pace
und verändert sondern aus einem und
identifizierbaren Bild wird ein neues
Bild hergestellt und wenn man eben
dieses Bild dann auch präzisiert z.B man
sagt man möchte jetzt diesen Hund aber
in schwarz dann kommt das auch raus und
das macht halt der Computer in dieser
Black Box wo wir eben nicht ganz
reingucken können und nicht ganz wissen
was genau passiert denn da ich glaube
aber dass dieser Prozess ist wichtig für
diese ganze Diskussion und es führt halt
eben dazu dass man auch hier sowas dann
herstellen kann da habe ich ein
Weihnachtsmann mit einem Laserschwert
dargestellt
gibt es das nee gab es noch nicht glaube
ich so und jetzt habe ich halt irgendwie
aus meiner Idee heraus durch ai dieses
Bild kreieren können und
das führt mich zu einer neuen Ebene von
dem ganzen und zwar zu der Kombination
von kultureller Symbole
hier links sehen wir habe ich also die
Beschreibung könnt ihr lesen genau einen
alten Mann der aus dem Fenster schaut in
dem Stil von Johannes wäre mehr und dann
gibt's da Vader als ganz prominentes
kultursymbol von Star Wars und dann
dachte ich mir wie witzig wäre es wenn
wir es machen dann kombinieren wir das
doch einfach und es klappt total gut
finde ich weil auch also hier sehen wir
dieser weiß blaue Boden den benutzt halt
Johannes wäre mir auch in seinem
gemelden immer dieses Licht dieses
gleiche Licht aus den Fenstern ist auch
ganz berühmt für seine Gemälde und ich
war einfach erstaunt dass es möglich ist
ja also dass man wirklich diese
Bilderwelten zusammenführen kann auf
eine sehr schnelle und interessante Art
und Weise
dasselbe kann man auch hier machen da
habe ich dann irgendwie einen ein Clown
Trooper als Starbucks Angestellter
einfach dargestellt weil ich mir dachte
dieses meme kommt zu dunklen Seite wir
haben Cookies irgendwie auch ganz gut zu
Starbucks passt
genau so ja Katzenbilder dürfen nicht
fehlen die kann man halt aber auch
extrem gestalten wie hier also wirklich
hier geht's ganz klar darum einfach mal
verschiedene Stile und
Darstellungsmöglichkeiten mal zu sehen
und
genau
irgendwann stellt man sich die Frage
okay erleiden wir ein Realitätsverlust
mit diesen Bildern die sind so
realistisch welches Bild davon ist jetzt
echt also ihr könnt euch gerade ich ich
löse es gleich auf stellt euch gerne die
Frage welches davon echt ist eines davon
ist generiert und das andere ist von dem
Online Shop auf Instagram Foto und das
spannende fand ich einfach dass ich also
dass das wirklich auf einem Level ist wo
ich so war wow also selbst mir als
jemand der das relativ gut erkennt
nachdem ich halt tausende von solchen
Bildern gesehen habe fällt mir halt bei
dem jetzt relativ schwer und ähm dieses
Fotoshooting hat eine Stunde gedauert
mindestens oder zwei das Bild zu
generieren hat halt eben ja 3 Minuten
gedauert oder so und äh die Auflösung
ist eben das linke Bild ist generiert
und das rechte ist ein Foto
ähm genau
jetzt gibt es natürlich auch die
Variante auch die man auch bei mit
journey verwenden kann wir hatten jetzt
also immer Text zu Bild wir hatten eine
Beschreibung und dann kam Bild raus und
es gibt auch die Möglichkeit andere
Inputs zu wählen und eins davon ist halt
Bild und Text woraus dann neues Bild
entsteht das habe ich jetzt einfach weil
es alle gemacht haben wollte ich auch
wissen was passiert mit meinem Foto mit
meinem Profilbild wenn ich das einfach
so sagt nimm das Bild und transformierst
doch bitte in einem
ich weiß nicht in irgendeinen Stil neues
Profilbild das habe ich dann gemacht und
die Ergebnisse waren halt so das was wir
hier sehen genau und da war ich
überrascht weil ich mir dachte krass
also ja anscheinend schaue ich da dann
doch sehr feminin auch aus für die AI
und wer hat hier als äh ja 1920 mäßig
dargestellt und dann habe ich das halt
angepasst und und habe das dann noch mal
formuliert in einer ganz anderen Art und
Weise ich habe dann gesagt okay
of this portrait Mann ich musste dann
noch mal ein Mann spezifizieren und dann
her und artistic style und dann kam halt
ein ganz anderes Bild raus aber nur so
als Beispiel man kann diese Inputs auch
kombinieren genau
und ja
ich glaube das ist so jetzt erstmal dazu
jetzt kommen wir glaube ich zu mehr
inhaltlichen Dingen also Kreativität ist
auch eine Frage ist also und genau
kreativ also ich gehe einfach mal weiter
hier zum zwei Begriffe also ich glaube
bei es ist so dass man eben bei diesen
Generatoren oder Generatoren ist es so
dass das eine gewisse Art von
Kreativität erforderlich ist weil warum
ich habe Freunde gehabt die irgendwie
das Ding in der Hand hatten dann einen
Text reingeschrieben haben und sowas
reinschreiben dieses symbol of freedom
ich finde es ist eine wichtige also das
ist ein tolles Experiment man kann sich
fragen okay stell doch mal das Symbol
für Frieden da sorry für Freiheit und
dafür das Böse und dann gucken wir mal
was rauskommt das ist irgendwie sowas
spielerisches und man kann sagen ach das
ist ja interessant und dann kann man da
irgendwie rein interpretieren ach eine
Ei hat dieses Verständnis von Freiheit
dem ist jetzt glaube ich aber nicht dass
es nicht der Fall ich glaube der hat
einen Ball ist weil hier sind die
Ergebnisse musste davon ich habe nur das
eingetippt dann kam beim bösen kam hier
so Satanismus raus okay vielleicht kann
man sagen ist sehr treffend aber dennoch
irgendwie sehr klischeehaft und hier
links sehen wir das Symbol für Freiheit
richtig dick und fett Amerika mit einem
Adler der Flagge
dann doch ganz interessant ist dass
diese zwei Versionen hier rechts dann
ein Adler in dem Käfig ist der dann doch
nicht so frei ist das fand ich dann doch
ganz cool aber ich glaube die
Interpretation darüber ob die hier
irgendwie ähm ja ob man dann mehr wert
draußen ich glaube wir haben nur der
einzige Mehrwert den wir daraus ziehen
ist wir erkennen was für Bilder in der
Datenbank sind das ist der einzige
Mehrwert ansonsten ist unsere
Kreativität gefragt um das Symbol für
Freiheit mit einer KI zu erstellen und
da habe ich eben dann meine Versuche
gehabt fürs böse und fürs für die
Freiheit und bei der Freiheit habe ich
halt hier einen Schlüssel dargestellt
und beim bösen ein einen Apfel was auch
das Cover fürs Hörbuch sein wird von von
Jörg Knaller für Theorien des Bösen das
wird das kann man jetzt sein ähm ich
habe wir hatten ursprünglich Adam und
Eva aber die die verlege von den
Hörbüchern hatten ein Problem wenn das
wegen Nacktheit von einem alten Gemälde
das jetzt haben wir halt die Möglichkeit
einfach selber mit AI das schnell mal
was anderes da zu erstellen genau
[Musik]
das sind jetzt die Beispiele für wie man
Themen inhaltliche Themen darstellen
kann mit Real
genau jedes Werkzeug hatte seine eigenen
Stil ist die nächste Folie und das ist
halt auch was spannendes was ich also wo
ich wirklich glaube ich was ich einfach
am aller spannendsten finde und das habe
ich zum Beispiel noch nie mit jemanden
gesagt also sagen hören ist das
eigentlich ai ist also auch wenn sie auf
demselben Algorithmus laufen
unterschiedliche ähm ja so
Fingerabdrücke haben also man kann fast
erkennen dass die eine Kategorie an
Bildern von der einei generiert wurde
und die andere Kategorie von Bildern von
der anderen her ja also das ist so ein
bestimmter Stil drinnen das versteckt
wieder auf warum auf Basis der Datenbank
natürlich und hier haben wir wieder
unseren Kaktus unseren
Hauptprotagonisten dieser dieser ganzen
Geschichte und links sind die also exakt
die selben Beschreibungen ähm bloß halt
einmal von Dali 2 generiert also von der
Open von dem Open iPhone zu mit journey
und rechts eben von mit journey
generiert und ja da könnt ihr einfach
mal gucken ich finde es ganz interessant
diese schwarz-weiß Version ist bei mit
journey wesentlich
schöner das ist halt auch ja also links
schaut aus wie eine Kinderzeichnungen
rechts so ein bisschen anspruchsvoller
hingegen ist dieses
gefaltete Papier unglaublich realistisch
bei bei Dolly 2 und bei journey hat so
ein bisschen so ein
3ds-stil irgendwie und da ist es halt
wie eine Fotografie hier links und so
weiter
genau dasselbe habe ich glaube ich noch
mal ja also noch mal detailliert auf die
schwarz-weiß Version um noch mal ganz
präzise zu sehen okay das wirklich ein
anderer Stil also ich finde man kann
sehen bei der Menge von 4 Bildern schon
ja Dalli erstellt mit demselben Befehl
die Bilder dann offen auf eine andere
Art und Weise und das ist wieder eine
also es ist eine Restriktion eine
Eigenschaft man kann sein wie man es
will aber es ist eine Sache die man halt
sich zu Nutze machen kann in meine Augen
und ähm das ich sehe deine parallele
auch zu wie wie damals also wenn man
halt ein Bild mal kann man sich
entscheiden welchen Pinsel nimmt man
oder nimmt man vielleicht irgendwas zum
ja also
ein bisschen Schaber und und dann schabt
man irgendwie die Farbe so über die
Leinwand und dann hat man halt einen
unterschiedlichen Stil und das ist halt
auch hier irgendwie steckt mit drin ich
das so finde
genau jetzt kommen wir zu disruption es
ist logische Parallelen zwischen
zwischen einer neuen Technologie ich
möchte hier ai mit Fotografie
vergleichen wir hatten eben im 19
Jahrhundert den Realismus in der Malerei
ich habe hier ein relativ bekanntes Bild
genommen was als Beispiel oft
hergenommen wird dafür dass dieses
Gemälde in der Zeit der Fotografie
hergestellt wurde warum weil die
Perspektive halt äußerst also die
Perspektive ist eine die man wie mit
einer Kamera einfangen kann und
das Bild hat zwei bis acht Wochen Arbeit
wahrscheinlich das ist eine Schätzung
von mir gedauert das zu malen und der ja
die das es geht beim Realismus eben um
die Darstellung der Alltagswelten
dasselbe könnte man mit einer Kamera zur
selben Zeit 1849 vielleicht nicht mit
also da noch nicht nicht alle aber in
dem Zeitraum des Ende des 19
Jahrhunderts in zwei bis acht Sekunden
je nach Belichtungszeit auch
abfotografieren mit der Kamera man hätte
selber Motiv dieselbe Idee es werden nur
ein anderes Werkzeug was man benutzt
es gibt also eine aufgabenverschiebung
in dieser Zeit von aha die Malerei als
unter anderem als als eine Handwerk
hatte zur Aufgabe die Realität
abzubilden man hat Porträts gemalt hier
ist eine Ansammlung von den Sultan im
Osmanischen Reich vom wie gesagt mit das
äh 20 19 Jahrhunderts bis Anfang 20 und
das ist hier chronologisch also wir
sehen ähm Mahmut der zweite hatte
Gemälde Abdullah süß hatte dann schon
Fotos und der nach ihm hat dann noch mal
gemelde gemacht und dann das war der
letzte und dann gab es nur noch Fotos
von den Sultan bis zum ersten Krieg dann
und
ich sehe hier halt eine
Aufgabenverteilung in dem Sinn dass man
eben das dass die Fotografie den einen
Job nicht den gesamten Job der Malerei
aber den einen Job übernommen hat und
zwar Realität abbilden und
Familienporträts mussten auch nicht mehr
gemalt werden eine Arbeiterfamilie
konnte sich auf einmal leisten sich
abbilden zu lassen mit einer Kamera das
ist glaube ich sowas ähnliches erleben
wir jetzt mit der AI Kunst also wie ich
zum Beispiel anstatt dass ich mich
selber ran Hocke und wirklich zwei
Wochen an einem an einem Bild an der
Illustration sitzt und arbeite kann ich
jetzt dieses Tool benutzen und ähm da
mir halt unglaublich viel Zeit sparen
ähm genau und ich glaube und das ist
natürlich auch disruptiv weil weil dann
wahrscheinlich diese also bestimmte
Dienstleistungen im Bereich Kunst und
Illustrationen verloren gehen aber ich
glaube es betrifft eben den
Dienstleistungsbereich und nicht den
Kunstbereich weil Kunst ist aber auch
die Frage ist kundendienstleistung oder
was anderes
als Gegenreaktion also ist die Malerei
ausgestorben nee ist sie nicht wir haben
gegen Reaktion erlebt Wladimir kann
Denis geben blauer Reiter van Gogh die
haben halt eben dann gesagt okay wenn
die wenn die Fotografie die Realität
abbilden kann was soll dann die Malerei
zeigen von der Realität und dann gibt es
halt eben die Impressionisten und so
weiter oder abstrakte Kunst das ist
glaube ich was was ich auch hier ganz
stark machen will als Punkt und
genau jetzt haben wir natürlich jetzt
kann man diese Fotografie diese diese
Phase diesen Übergang also man könnte
sich fragen okay was ist dann das die
Eigenschaften davon so jeder kann es mit
Leichtigkeit benutzen es kommen sofort
Bilder raus es ist disruptiv wie wir
gerade gesehen haben und es gibt so eine
Mensch Maschine Interaktion wo man
keinen Kontakt mehr mit dem echten
Handwerk der Malerei zu tun hat
so und das selbe trifft halt auch jetzt
die Fusion zu man hat kann ja genau und
[Musik]
zum Schluss möchte ich jetzt hier auf
die Potenziale eingehen das ist so ein
eigenes Projekt was ich jetzt in die
Wege geleitet habe es ist sehr sehr geht
das voran aber ich ich bleib halt dran
das ist eben ich habe es Vater Sohn und
künstliche Intelligenz genannt
was im Prinzip die Beschäftigung von mir
mit der Kunst meines Vaters der 2021
verstorben ist zu tun hat und genau und
hier ist es so also mein Vater andreas
ohrenschall hat halt viele also wirklich
viele viele gehabt viele Gemälde gemalt
hat dann immer auch eine spirituelle
Frage dahinter bei dem Wasser gemalt hat
und ähm deswegen auch der Projekttitel
nichtsdestotrotz wie gesagt die die Art
die Kunstwerke sind vielseitig also hier
sehen wir so Fantasie Traumwesen die ihr
dargestellt hat teilweise auch in
Alltagsszenen deswegen auch der Hut
aber auch aus den 90er Jahren satirische
Zeichnungen Karikaturen wo er
Gesellschaftssystem angesprochen hat
auch hier dann guage Skizzen und
Malereien dir die er gemacht hat zu
solchen also ja ich genau ich kann auch
nicht alles ich weiß auch nicht alles
über seine Gedankenprozesse aber hier
nur ein paar Beispielbilder und ein ganz
prominentes ist halt seine Kaiser sein
Kaiserwalzer hat er ihn genannt das ist
eben eine Reihe es gibt noch viel mehr
Kaiser die ja eben gemalt hat und sich
da halt historisch auch mit der Thematik
der Habsburger auseinandergesetzt hat
und ich habe jetzt eben das ist ein
Potential von Real was ich sehe ich kann
halt jetzt eher nutzen die Kunst von
meinem Vater nehmen und nicht unbedingt
nachmachen aber in Kontakt damit treten
auf eine neue Art und Weise ich kann
nämlich halt fragen so was sehe ich im
Bild kriege ich das repliziert mit der
Ei und was ist das Ergebnis und wenn ich
es nicht repliziert Kriege komme ich
vielleicht auf neue Gedanken und ähm
daran bin ich gerade am experimentieren
wie gesagt und das nur mal um meinen
Workflow darzustellen habe ich hier eine
Grafik also ich habe hier das Bild von
meinem Vater
habe dann einen Text Befehl als Input
und sag halt dann meine Beschreibung
dass ich hier in österreichischen
Kaiser sehen in einer goldenen ähm in
einer goldenen Rüstung mit dem roten
Mantel und er steht also ich beschreibt
das Bild auf die Art und Weise wie es
halt sehen und es interessant ist man
könnte jetzt denken na ja das ist ja die
objektive Beschreibung
aber das ist es halt nicht weil man
schnell merkt ach die Ergebnisse sind
aber da kommt halt was komisch also da
kommen wir halt was anderes raus und man
könnte auch fragen sich fragen naja
vielleicht wenn ich das wem anders
gegeben hätte der hatte das Bild auch
anders beschrieben vielleicht hat er die
Vögel übersehen oder hat sich viel mehr
auf diese dunkle Frau im Vordergrund
fokussiert also ich zum Beispiel
komplett ja ausgelassen habe und was ich
halt dann cool fand ist einfach wie
vielseitig und unglaublich schön auf
diese Bilder aussehen die da entstanden
sind hier rechts oben zum Beispiel ähm
teilweise auch noch mit mit journey
Version 3 entstanden nur zur Info mit
der neuen Version habe ich es nicht
ausprobiert und ja und da da bin ich
halt jetzt dabei dass man dass ich halt
einfach wirklich einfach mache mache und
dann dokumentiert und mich dann noch mal
also mit ein paar Fragen
auseinandersetze bei der ganzen Sache
aber ich sag mal so ähm mit EA ist es
mir halt jetzt möglich diese also auch
unvollständige Unfall unvollständige
Zyklen von meinem Vater irgendwie
vorzuführen nicht auf die Art dass ich
ihm nachmachen will oder irgendwie da
seine Kunst kopieren will sondern auf
eine Art dass man halt dass ich in
Kontakt trete und eben als Sohn da
irgendwie weiter mich mit diesen
Thematiken beschäftigen kann das Gute
ist ja auch viel aufgeschrieben das
heißt auch seine Schrift kann ich
eigentlich auch dafür benutzen um da
irgendwie ja zu experimentieren und
genau eine Möglichkeit die ich noch
nicht erkundet habe ist eben mal all die
Fotos zu in den Datenbank ein also eine
Datenbank ein zu speisen und dann zu
gucken ob die KI auch seinen Stil
nachahmen kann wobei ich das eher so als
relativ also das finde ich dann wiederum
eher ein bisschen oberflächlich als als
Idee tatsächlich ähm genau das wäre dann
vielleicht für ihn als Künstler
interessant dass er seinen Stil
einspeist und dann halt produzieren
könnte
ja und so habe ich jetzt mal
schlagwortartig und assoziativ dieses
ganze Thema für heute behandelt genau
und ähm ja will vielleicht noch
zusammenfassend sagen muss man jetzt was
dafür können und ich glaube ja man
braucht gute Ideen man muss verstehen
wie man diese Wort Befehle schreibt also
diese Proms
man muss am Ende wie ein Fotograf auch
muss man das richtige Ergebnis wählen
also ein Fotografen macht auch tausend
Bilder und er nimmt nur drei davon also
die ein geschmackten Kunst Erfahrung ist
wichtig um das auch irgendwie produktiv
und künstlerisch nutzen zu können und
und vielleicht als letztes Statement zu
dem ganzen Thema ich glaube auch dass
wir sehr schnell übersättigt werden von
diesen generated images weil sobald
etwas leicht zu machen ist und dass alle
tun wird nicht nur erkennbar sondern es
wird auch einfach vom übersättigt sein
unser Geschmack wird übersättigt sein
vielleicht sehen man sich nach
unperfekten Ergebnissen die Hand gemacht
sind und das ist so ein bisschen
deswegen ich da auch relativ
hoffnungsvoll bin dass das ganze ja
nicht nichts schlechtes ist in unserer
Gesellschaft ja und ich glaube das war's
danke fürs zuhören